as fast as the wind and as powerful as a
hurricane oh nice new TT RS is the
sporty spearhead of the TT series its
look has gotten sharper and a bit more
aggressive fittingly because the TT RS
has a new more powerful 5-cylinder turbo
engine a 7-speed dual-clutch
transmission distributes the power to
all four wheels in gonda our cart
estimate Oscar at says the interior is
pretty much like a normal TTS but the
start/stop button and the drive select
button to choose the driving mode are
found on the steering wheel and in the
center console where a regular TT has it
start stop button the TT RS as a button
that can shift the sound of the muffler
from normal to sporty
the coolest on the biggest change that
matters notes is the newly developed
five-cylinder engine under the hood it
weighs less yet boasts more power than
its predecessor MIT einem totally
tabitha the vista me but in frog a model
not Jewish these alters or undersigned
mere liye stone Audi's engineers have
shaved 26 kilos of a new engine alone
and that improves the cars dynamics this
roadster accelerates from 0 to 100 just
3.9 seconds top speed is normally capped
at 250 km/h but can be raised at 280
kilometers an hour on request not really
tell the altima panel on the steering
wheel allows the driver to shift
manually but Montes says the
transmission is so well tuned especially
in sport mode that you'd hardly ever
need the manual shift I miss nauseas a
vault
Aladin is muslim but he says you need to
be careful the powerful motor and good
handling can tempt you to drive too fast
on country roads Tatsu dustman Haifa to
chanel of the lunch doesn't exist Marcus
is testing the TT RS near Madrid not far
from the 3.5 kilometers akito da gama
racecourse with its 13 curves
why does SVRs and Audi tt-rs stands for
racing sport monta says that's why he's
come to the our AMA circuit where in the
1970s and 80s Formula One giants like
niki lauda James Hunt and Gillian oof
had their great successes to test the
car on the track Montes trades the
Roadster for the second body variant the
coop a that has two advantages first he
can see how well the coop a performs as
a race car and second he can compare the
roadster and the coop a directly
submission roadster one copy
from 0 to 100 3.7 seconds the TT coupe a
has never been this fast before the new
five-cylinder engine produces 294
kilowatts of power 44 more than its
predecessor torque is a whopping 480
Newton metres a traction control system
ensures maximum acceleration with a
minimum of slippage otherwise especially
on curves is Titus here on the racetrack
says montes you notice how broad the
area is in which the engine delivers the
maximum torque of 480 Newtons he's quite
impressed with how well and how fast he
comes out of the curves of course you
have to be careful not to accelerate too
much he says depending on the curve the
car's rear could swing out too much so
you have to take care but if you haven't
completely deactivated the ESP it keeps
things under control slowing the car in
plenty of time but not too soon the
hospital em stein and on our funding to
food abba a menage a scientist I
the car has the typical sound of a five
cylinder engine and two oval exhaust
tailpipes
new matrix o LED taillights with a 3d
design our eye catchers this is the
first time they've been part of a
standard Audi
I'll be too dear the Audi tt-rs costs
around seventy thousand euros montes
says there's no denying you'll notice
the difference from super cars like the
Porsche 911 Turbo or honda nsx which
deliver even greater performance on the
track but for a car in this price class
the audi is very powerful indeed thanks
to its permanent all-wheel drive vocally
there zia oddly
Junior said let's go pee the coop a
performs better than the Roadster on the
racetrack says Montes first it
accelerates a tad faster but more
importantly its roof is more torsion
resistant which lets you reach greater
speeds in the curves but since he
regards the TT RS as a car mainly made
for fun and since he rarely drives on a
racetrack matta says he choose the
roadster version Oh food in roadster in
China
in Germany the price where the coupe a
starts at just over 66,000 euros the
Roadster will set you back around 3,000
euros more
you